Caribbean just walked in we're
dissecting the Prince Andrew it's so
great we've got a great clip yeah for
you here put those headphones on care
feed him fabulous New York City comedian
so many pictures he's saying he doesn't
remember yes I remember her and also he
was didn't sweat at the time and she
said he was sweaty so she's she's making
it up because he medically couldn't
sweat as a professional sweater Yeah
right you sweat a lot it's true I put
out your armpits they should be
nicknamed Seattle very moist no now he
sweats it was just at the period
coincidentally the period of time that
the woman accused him of having sex with
her being trafficked to him when she was
a minor coincidentally that same exact
period of time he had a medical
condition that he didn't sweat and she
said he was sweaty which brings the
whole story into question Botox what
would you have that would prevent you
from sweating that's what I think you're
right they injects like Botox in your
armpit glands or something I mean you're
fading your face does it stop you from
well he gets he gets into it he gets
into all the reasons why he really is
quite sure that he did not have sex with
this underage girl he's but you know
he's pretty sure he's got a lot of
reasons why it again this is 2001 - so
with you know Botox well yes they were
doing a temple is big wasn't nearly he's
making 2001 but if anybody has access to
it it's the Royals although if he did
Botox he probably would have fixed his
bottom teeth - no they don't even care
they all look awful over there so it's
like there's nothing to compare it to
maybe you're right
you're probably right worst dental
hygiene yeah the standards right now
he's a jab I mean I get what you're
probably right it is right they're all
mellow and brown that's right pointy
they have like all canines that's right
like in front it's
she says she met you in 2001 she dined
with you she danced with you you bought
her drinks you're in Trump nightclub in
London and she went on to have sex with
you in a house in Belgravia belonging to
girl in Maxwell such a liar
cuz that she's listing it he's going
like yeah yeah yep yep no jobs I don't
dance
I am religious like in Footloose you'd
think they'd be outraged if somebody was
like here's the list of things that this
person said happen I'd be like this is a
crazy person now one of those things
happen right Trump nightclub like if he
was a real Road heavens to Murgatroid
here's the thing I don't remember that
so I feel like it probably didn't happen
well just say you go I go there a lot of
danced a lot just act like you were
drunk and you didn't remember like your
dad Don so you know if your friends
don't dance they're no friends of mine
right there are a number of things that
are wrong with that story one of which
is that is that I don't know where the
bar isn't in tramps no one thought you
were going up there to get it yourself
I've never worked as a parking attendant
do you think they might have had table
service yeah just means you paid the
bill he paid you to order her a drink
from summer yeah where's the bar as a
drink for her don't know where the boys
member dancing at trunk no that couldn't
have happened because the date that
there's being suggestive I was at home
with the children you know the children
being the one I was sleeping and when I
say home I mean Jeffrey Epstein with
some children
why did he see this earlier I don't know
he just came up with he's just like all
right he is he good I mean I actually
believe this region is very believable
do you home with the children
was it a memorable night on that
particular day that that we now
understand is the date which is the 10th
of March I behind I was taken by
interest to a pizza express in working
for a party I remember I was ordering
Pizza Pizza
I called Little Caesars Express all I
could think about when he said like I
couldn't have been having sex with
underage girls because I was at Pizza
Express I was like oh good well luckily
there's never been any grand pedophile
cover-up conspiracies tied to pizza
restaurants before one more Jim and Sam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM app
[Music]